now today we're going to talk about the
most dangerous food that you could
potentially eat not that you would ever
eat this food but
if you did
i believe it's the most dangerous and i
looked at a lot of different factors
um which i'm going to discuss but before
i get into it i'm very curious what you
think is the most dangerous food for
your health go ahead and comment in the
section down below i'm very curious and
as i go through this let's see if you
can guess what it is
the first point i want to bring up is
that
it combines
a starch
and a fat together under high heats okay
so that's the first thing so anytime you
combine
a starch or carb with a fat or protein
and you heat it up
you create this very interesting
compound called
an advanced
glycation and product now what is that
well that's just a compound that really
becomes sticky in your body and it just
locks up
all sorts of
cells and tissues in the eye
in the brain
in the heart in the kidney and it makes
these tissues not able to function
correctly now if you think of your blood
sugars for example you would get a test
done called a1c
which
is this it's glycation of a protein so
basically you're measuring like a three
month exposure
to sugar because the sugar in your blood
combines with the protein in your blood
it's called hemoglobin the protein it
destroys it and it makes it unavailable
to function so when they measure a1c
they're determining how much of your
hemoglobin is
stuck to sugar basically and so the
higher you have it the more diabetes and
complications you have and the less you
have it the healthier you are all right
the next ingredient is hydrogenated oils
either cottonseed
or it could be corn oil hydrogenated
that means there's trans fats trans fats
are very very bad it makes your cells
like plastic it hardens the arteries
there's reports that it triggers cancer
i mean it does a lot of damage inside
the body and a lot of foods have gone
away from hydrogenated oils but not all
types of foods all right the next thing
this food has if you want to call it a
food is acrylamide
acrylamide occurs when you deep fry
certain
root vegetables okay i could just give
you a hint there
under high heats you create this
neurotoxin called acrylamide
okay
it's been links to
alzheimer's because it affects the
neurons or the next ingredient is sugar
and in the u.s i mean a great majority
of the sugar is b sugar which is gmo so
we have glyphosate and then we have
sugar and so we know what sugar does it
creates all sorts of issues i don't need
to get into that but
the type of sugar is not even sugar cane
usually it's going to be
either
beet sugar or dextrose or they just
might add dextrose that's a synthetic
sugar okay
or another type of sugar which is not
even classified as a sugar called
maltodextrin now what's fascinating
about maltodextrin
is that because they manipulated this
carbohydrate
to a
polysaccharide which is many
sugars they can classify it as a starch
and not as sugar so when you look at the
label it's not under sugars it's under
carbohydrates so it makes it seem like
it's low sugar but on the glycemic index
maltodextrin it is the highest thing in
the glycemic index so when you consume
something with maltodextrin you're
consuming something that's really going
to raise your blood sugars in a big way
and create
a high insulin it's called
hyperinsulinemia
and there's so many complications that
occur from high insulin and malt
deduction is made from either rice
wheat
or
corn all right i want to come back to
this chemical called glyphosate it's
what they use as an herbicide called
roundup ready and it's involved in gmo
foods but there are certain foods that
they spray a lot of this glyphosate on
and i won't tell you exactly what food
it is you'll have to guess but they
spread on oats lentils
soy lentils would be like peanuts
beans
wheat
potato
sugar beets and corn if you research
glyphosate you'll see that it's really
safe for humans
but it's not very safe for
microorganisms
so when they spray the soil it can kill
certain microbes because they also got a
patent
to classify glyphosate as an antibiotic
because it kills microbes well the
question is do we have any microbes
in or on our body and the answer is yes
we do do we depend on them yes we do is
it possible that this glyphosate can
alter our microbiome of course you're
going to have a lot of biased answers on
that but i think you can
all right the next ingredient is
seed oils okay as in corn canola
cottonseed
soy peanut or safflower or sunflower and
they might use different combinations of
these oils but they
use them in very high heats and usually
if you buy this food in a restaurant
they're frying this food in this oil
multiple times if not you know weeks to
a month so the more that you use this
oil and you deep fry something over and
over
you create an incredible
oxidation which means it's very very
inflammatory is giving you a lot of
advanced glycation end products which is
clogging everything up it's giving you
trans fats it's giving you a lot of
sugar and high levels of insulin it's
giving you glyphosate which can affect
the digestive system in a big way and it
usually comes with ketchup
can you guess what it is
it is french fries well the good thing
about ketchup is that it's just another
vegetable right
i think if i'm not mistaken it is
classified or counted as a vegetable
but ketchup is basically
high fructose corn syrup there's so much
sugar in it high fructose corn syrup is
going to go to the liver and that's
going to create a fatty liver okay it's
going to then create insulin resistance
other than that
perfectly healthy and they also add
additional
sugar as corn syrup so i don't know why
they have to add corn syrup on top of
high fructose corn syrup i don't
understand that but they also add
modified corn starch okay another thing
that can raise your blood sugars also
modified corn starch
usually is msg a flavor enhancer to make
the food taste better than it really is
which by the way again increases
insulin and they use modified cornstarch
to
enhance mouth feel to give a food
texture that's why they're using it
they're not using it as a sweetener and
then of course in ketchup they had the
soy oil which
is not only
estrogenic
but it's an oil that has hexane so we
have this product a french fry that has
advanced glycation end products trans
fats
tons of not just regular sugar but sugar
that can really jack up your blood
sugars we have a product that's loaded
with glyphosate that we don't even know
all the side effects that that's going
to create over time we have a product
that's been deep fried and oil that who
knows how long that oil's been sitting
there so we have this potato starch that
acts as a sponge that just soaks up all
this omega-6 fatty acid which is highly
inflammatory and then of course we
sprinkle a little salt on it right maybe
not sea salt just regular sodium
chloride which usually has
aluminum
and of course because of the heating
process there's acrylamide so there's a
lot of bad foods out there but i really
think based on what i just talked about
the french fry
with ketchup is at the top of the list
but what's really hilarious if you do a
search on the food that is the most
carcinogenic or the food that is the
most unhealthy you know it'll be number
one on google search it'll be red meat
and processed meat that's what they're
saying is the most unhealthy which is so
far from the actual truth because there
are so many other foods that are
incredibly unhealthy for you now of
course no one just has the french fries
they usually have a hamburger with the
bun with additional things and then you
have the liquid candy i'm sorry a soda
with that which is more high fructose
corn syrup
so instead of depressing you more let's
talk about the
the healthy foods that you should be
concentrating on i put that up right
here check it out